I did something with my hair and I don't
know how I feel about it it's not for
talkback Tuesday let's start over on
sometimes my stomach gets gross and
three seven seven for a new person to
person to person and three seven seven
for more like not does not compute r2d2
did it first
robots can do this they don't have
joints boys straighten the gray
something and I we're running a race at
Macy's and kicking tables over while the
employees talked about how unstable we
are what's that a dream I always think
about kicking over things and not
getting things out in people's hands so
I saw a man carrying a package the other
day and I was jogging and I thought what
would happen if I just went and kept on
my way today I walk by someone holding
the cake oh that's gonna be a tough one
to avoid Lindsey new person to person to
person Lindsey dirt more like Lindsey do
do the worst there has been a great
thing for the world boo boo boo I don't
give Dakota for free will evening that
if i watch it isn't really met you much
it I mean like I get it and please don't
I can't force you I just can
mind-control you not to
though the hairstyle has put up some
sort of force field for my mind-control
tongue because sometimes your stomach
your tummy can't
dum-dum-dum feeling sorry for you person
to person to person feeling sorry for
more like feeling sorry for the first
thing that has to wait for you to finish
your sentence of what you're sorry for
like sorry for what you baboon showing
my friends Camp Takota makes me the
happiest person yeah share that thank
really thick movie cost $9.99 what I was
getting at first $9.99 you can get some
computer printer paper but that doesn't
have a subplot of romance
Trinity means you person to person to
person Trinity beams more like Trinity
me me me me me me me me me this is a
comedy this is just making noises this
is a diary of a woman slowly falling
into helpless peril of her own brain
insanity
don't forget to like this video we've
been prey my desktop background game is
strong memory heart has some competition
now let's go over to fast and tasty
heartburn relief they're trying to make
it sound cute that your stomach he's
puking on the inside and outside
Matthew Delgado new person to person in
person my food without a mark Matthew
del Taco great franchise delicious cheap
tacos always reliable also they have
taco salads excellent variety group
improve sound making videos please I
can't but I do love that skull marine
ravage new person new person to person
skull marine rabbit looks like you have
heard some people in your day probably
physically do it right that's none of
your business if you don't like them
don't watch them if you don't like them
go watch them there's literally at least
like six other videos on YouTube that
might appeal to your tastes Tommy Joey
ling-ling new person to person to person
Tommy Todd leaning more like tapping
ling-ling ling-ling ling-ling ling-ling
hear that that's the alarm that says you
got the greatest last name of all time
hey I'm worth the middle finger hotel
cafe junkie new person to person to
person hotel cafe junkie more like wow
you have interest in hobbies
scubapro dude friends should become a
thing it's now as a thing great job
okay there's ever talking back to you on
Tuesday with just a day I don't know
we heard tell big new person new person
to person we hard to help make more like
we sharp smell bags what mamrie Hart
just took over my mind for a moment
store boy I might piss out hold on I'm
hoping that's a great new word Oh
don't forget that there are a limited
number of tickets left for the Boston
show that memory and I are doing on
March 15th this this no next Saturday
thank I always tell to write the show
and there's special guest Flula do
Jethro Allah will be there it's gonna be
great link is down below buy those
tickets Camp Takota calm